-Kevin Nealon.
-Wow.
-Looking good, bud.
-That's all I can say is wow.
-Looking good.
We both have beards.
-I have a beard.
I'm growing one for a movie.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
I'm going to see "Top Gun."
[ Laughter ]
-You're growing it to go see it?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Congratulations.
Last time I saw you, by the way,
I don't know
if you remember this.
We were in Washington, D.C.
-That's right.
-At the Kennedy Center Honors.
-Honoring Lorne Michaels.
-Yeah.
-You were so funny that night.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations.
You were really great.
We got to hang out a long time.
-Yeah, we did.
I loved being there
because it was a lot of people.
All the "SNL" people.
A lot of those people that had
been on "SNL" honoring Lorne.
And we get to hang out
in the green room
with all these people.
-We were doing bits and --
-Yeah, were punching
everybody's jokes up.
-It was almost
too many bits for me.
I actually got tired.
-It really was.
-I think it was like five hours
I was there.
And I go,
"I'm ready to take a nap."
-It was a long day.
-Everyone did bits.
And so it was a long day. I
don't know if you remember this.
I was leaving to go --
They said, "Mr. Fallon,
do you want to go change
in a hotel and put on a tuxedo?"
I go, "Yeah, I need to get out
of here
because everyone is doing
too many bits."
-You were exhausted.
-I was tired.
So I'm leaving.
I go to get into my car.
And they go, "Kevin Nealon wants
to say something to you."
And I go, "Oh, okay.
Where is he?"
They go, "He's in his car."
So I left my car.
I walked across the parking lot.
And you were sitting in the back
of your limousine with the
window rolled down.
I go, "What's up, Kevin?"
And you looked at me,
and the window rolled up
and you peeled away.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It was the funniest thing --
It was the funniest thing
at the perfect time.
I was exhausted.
I was like, "What's up, bud?
Anything for you."
And you just looked at me
and then the window rolled up.
And you took off.
-That was not my fault.
-No?
-My driver was real bossy.
-Oh, yeah, right.
-And he wanted to get home.
And I said, "No, I just called
Jimmy. He's coming over."
He goes, "No, I got to go."
And he starts driving away.
I was furious.
I said, "You got to go back."
He goes, "No, I'm taking you
back to your hotel."
I lunged over the seat.
I grabbed him by the throat.
-Oh, my God.
I said, "You got to go back."
-That's a crazy story, Kevin.
I don't believe any of it.
[ Laughter ]
Grabbed him by the throat.
-I did.
-Let's talk about your book
"I Exaggerate:
My Brushes with Fame."
It's full of caricatures
that you've drawn of
different celebrities.
When did this start for you?
-Well, I always loved
drawing caricatures.
I was never that good at it
but I always kind of doodled
as a kid.
I had a painting of
my mother and father
framed as caricatures,
and they were great.
-That you did?
-No, I didn't do it.
Some artist in Paris did it.
And they were great.
They were pastels.
And I lay in bed every night
kind of looking at them.
And I think subconsciously
I was studying them
and how the guy drew them
and everything.
And then, you know, as I got
older, I started doing it more.
And then when I was on
airplanes, I started sketching
people when they were sleeping.
They're like --
[ Laughter ]
And I'd sketch them, you know.
-You would sketch them --
-Yeah.
And I never told them about them
about, though.
Some of those are in the book.
-Like on what?
-Just on a barf bag or a napkin.
[ Laughter ]
It's better to do it with
an empty barf bag.
Because yeah.
-You graduate to --
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And then, I was in "SNL."
The table reads, sometimes,
would get a little slow
and monotonous.
I would start -- if I wasn't
in a sketch, I would start
sketching the person
across from me,
whether it's Farley
or Dana Carvey.
You know, and then I'd just --
-We actually have --
this is in the book,
but this is a front page
of a script from "SNL."
-Jeff Daniels.
-Jeff Daniels and Farley was
probably sitting
across from you.
-He was sitting across from me.
-This is what you doodled.
-Yeah.
-That is Jeff Daniels.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Amazing.
And Chris Farley.
-So, that's the kind of stuff
I was doing before I kind of
got into it, really got into it.
-And then how did you go
to the next level?
-Well, a couple years ago,
I used to follow a lot of
these artists on Instagram,
like Jason Seiler and Paul Moyes
and some other ones, and
this guy was giving lessons,
Paul Moyes, over in England.
So they were 500 euros
for 10 lessons.
I thought, "I like his style.
I'm going to learn how to do it
like he does."
And so I took lessons from him
on Skype.
-That's how you learned how to
do it?
I mean, this is the photo.
This is the painting
that you did of Farley.
[ Audience aws ]
-Yeah.
-I mean, that's amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It almost comes right at you.
-I mean, that was
such a common look.
And on each -- So, each picture
on the opposite page has
a little anecdote
about that person
and the experience
I had with them.
By the way, all of these
are on kevinnealonart.com.
That's where you can find these
paintings and also my book.
-Yeah. Kevinnealonart.com.
I also saw one of my favorites.
Dana Carvey. You did Dana.
-Dana Carvey, yeah.
-That's Dana Carvey there
you did.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I noticed I wasn't in the book.
You know, it doesn't matter.
-Well, you should thank me
for that.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Here's the problem, Jimmy.
This has ruined my life.
Because as a caricature artist,
you look around.
Everyone you look at, you see
their features
that are outstanding.
So it's like walking through
a fun house every day.
And everybody looks kind of like
distorted and stuff.
And it's a little freaky.
-What about them sticks out?
A big nose or --
-Yeah, but now you -- you have,
like, -- you know, in fact,
I actually did one of you.
Let me get it out for you.
[ Cheers ]
Now, this one I really
enjoyed doing.
You don't really have a lot of
outstanding characteristics.
Well, do you want to hold it?
-Thank you.
-Do you want me to unveil it?
-I can do it, yeah.
Let me hold it.
Alright, this is it.
-Ready? I'm going to unveil it.
Ready?
One, two, three.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you kidding me?
Kevin!
I love it.
Kevin, I'm like -- this is --
I'm honored.
-Oh, I got to sign it.
I forgot to sign it.
-Yeah, could you?
-Yeah. Yeah, sure.
-Kevin, this is amazing.
-Oh, my pleasure, man.
My pleasure.
-You were one of my --
-Well, you know, it's not easy.
It's not easy, Jimmy.
-Thank you.
-No.
And, you know, sometimes
it takes me a long time.
I go through a little process.
You know, where I have to --
I'm not quite getting it right.
Do another one, another one,
another one. It's an evolution.
-We have a video that shows how
your portraits come together.
-Alright. This is you, I think.
Yeah.
Start like that.
-Wow.
-It takes a while.
-Wow!
-Spent a long time on you,
Jimmy.
-You're really -- Kevin, wow!
That's amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But here's the thing.
I didn't know he grew a beard
since I did this one.
I didn't know. And so, a couple
days, they told me.
So I had to add on to it.
And I didn't know how long
you're going to have that beard,
so I took some creative measures
here, and this is kind of
how I went about doing that.
-Me with a beard.
Yes. This is great.
Kevin.
-Yeah, I didn't know how long.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I didn't know how long
you were gonna have the beard.
-I got to say
I'm honored that you did this.
You're one of my favorite
comedians.
I've always looked up to you
and loved you.
And you've always been great
to me. This means a lot to me.
-Thank you, buddy.
-Thank you so much for this.
-It's $50.
-Also, by the way, if you want
to see something funny,
"Hiking with Kevin" returns for
its fourth season
on October 27th.
-That's right. October 27th.
-Oh, my gosh.
By the way, you film it.
You edit it. You do everything.
-I do it all, man.
I've done 100 hikes already.
I'm exhausted.
-But it's so good, but you
never -- you never let anyone
know who you're hiking with.
-No, it's always a surprise.
-But why?
-Because I like people to tune
in to see who it is.
-Yeah, but if you tell me who it
is, I would tune in.
-Well, I'm going to tell you who
it is this season.
I'll tell you a couple of them.
By the way, I started about four
or five years ago,
and the hikes were
very difficult, you know.
And each year it's getting
a little less, a little less,
and a little less,
and now it's flat.
-Walking to Starbucks
with Kevin.
[ Laughter ]
-But what I do, Jimmy, is if
it's flat, I'll hold the camera
on an angle so it looks
like we're going up a hill.
-So smart. Come on, buddy.
Come on.
I want to show everyone
a preview of
season four of
"Hiking with Kevin."
Take a look at this.
-You love the container store.
Am I right?
-I do. Yes.
The first time I went into a
container store, I lost my mind.
-Me too.
Let me ask you this.
-Yes?
-Who's your favorite Beatle?
-Your questions are terrible.
But -- No, I mean,
in a good way.
-♪ I'll be so blue
just thinking about you ♪
-You're good.
-When was the last time
you washed your car?
-[ Laughs ]
-This has just been
the most brutal
hour and a half of my life.
-Hey, Eugene.
-Kevin.
-Hey, buddy,
thanks for doing the hike.
-I didn't know it was today.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Kevin Nealon, everybody.
"Hiking with Kevin"
premieres October 27th.
His book "I Exaggerate:
My Brushes with Fame"
is available for pre-order
right now.
It's funny. It's awesome.
We'll be right back with
stand-up from Sabrina Wu.
Stick around, everybody.